obviously working with nikki has got to
be i mean she's
one of the greatest of all time yeah
she's super talented um shout out nikki
yeah shout out to nikki how weird was it
being like uh
you know with all the six nine [ __ ]
happening obviously
you you you're a white kid from [ __ ]
the niagara region so like whether or
not the dude's a snitch or not probably
doesn't matter to you
but did that kind of like uh
because i feel like that was his biggest
record at least that to me was the
feeling fifi's one of my biggest records
is supposed to be diamond well fifi's
like the only record i feel like he ever
dropped that like was like i really had
real crossover like potent i was like yo
this [ __ ] is like undeniable at that
point but like what was that i think it
was just perfect timing great timing on
on his behalf coming off nice for what
he was super hot nicky obviously you
know what i'm saying that's just a
knockout what was like the story behind
how that came together was the nikki
have a lot to do with it or was it six
nine thing first like
um i pulled up on him we made the record
in new york
and then we were like just like
brainstorming who we should get on it he
really wanted to get nicki on it he got
nikki on and then yeah it was over
because was this prior after you did no
frauds
i didn't know fraud's like 2017 20 2017.
this was like
we did the fifi record probably like
2018 2018
2018 yeah
shout out no fry's a bang or two no
frauds was so hard that was a banger
that was something that i remember like
drake called me he was like yo
he sent me the record and i was like
damn this [ __ ] must be crazy i got one
with nikki drake and wayne i was like
and it was like a statement record for
yeah i was like yeah it was like a
little because that was what she was
going through the remy martial yeah i
was like i remember i remember playing
that and like and like my parents i was
like upstairs i'm like damn this [ __ ]
crazy